[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kissing and this
is the show for you if you're bored with
people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know
nothing about trigonometry we don't
pretend to be the experts
we ask the experts our brilliant guest
this week is a controversial sociologist
who's suing
his cambridge college for dismissing him
uh after a controversy so now carl
welcome to trigonometry
good to be here i've made that really
sound really exciting i don't know how
exciting it is
welcome to the show uh for anyone who
doesn't know you just tell everybody who
you are
how are you where you are a little bit
about the story that that i just
mentioned
uh so i'm a sociologist uh
graduated from a phd at oxford a couple
of years ago
and i am interested in a variety of
different subjects
brexit european union political
attitudes psychometrics
personality evolution
and i came to prominence at least to a
small extent
uh following a controversy after my
appointment
at st edmonds college cambridge which
occurred
in the autumn of 2018.
basically some students and academics
made a series of complaints
to the college about me these complaints
were not trivial they allege that i was
a racist pseudo-scientist
and they called for a investigation into
my
appointment at the college an
investigation
was undertaken and five months later i
was dismissed from my role
at the college and made unemployed
so here i am today and i've decided to
try to take some kind of legal action
against the college
i know the face hit so here i am today
like this is my rock bottom
yeah this is what happens when you get
unemployed you end up on trigonometry
uh well welcome we can't talk about the
details of the case for legal reasons
uh but just in broad brushstrokes i mean
some of the accusations that were made
was that you're a pseudo scientist that
you were doing
research into these super controversial
race and iq stuff
um and uh one of the interesting things
as well that i wanted
to get you to touch on is that the vast
majority of the people who file
who supported the motion to have you
dismissed
were scientists or scholars in areas
that have nothing to do
with what you actually research so there
are people like english literature
professors
uh making assertions as to the validity
of your research so just give us an
overview of the whole situation
yeah so there was this open letter uh
sent to the newspapers in early december
which was initially signed by a couple
of hundred academics
and subsequently over the next few days
signed by 586 in total
and uh the headline of the open letter
was no to racist pseudoscience
at cambridge university uh where i'd
been employed
and the charges in the open letter were
that
i had been involved in uh
work that would be that could be
considered pseudoscientific and that i'd
attended a certain conference in london
called the london conference on
intelligence
and that my work had been
or was liable to be misused by certain
bad actors with the purpose of harming
vulnerable populations around the world
uh and as you correctly pointed out
the open letter was signed by a large
number of people many of whom
one would suspect probably didn't have
that much expertise in the relevant
areas
actually a research assistant and i went
through
the entire list of signatories and
identified the
subject for each one and we found
that only a relatively small number in
uh
subjects like biology or psychology i
think less than 10
in those disciplines which could be
considered relevant to the
subject matter at hand
a great deal we're in subjects like uh
gender studies and
critical race theory that's
qualitative sociology history and
english literature as you said
uh i i i'm hesitant to
completely dismiss someone's opinion
just because they're not in uh
the same field as me but in this case it
wouldn't be
totally unreasonable to presume many of
them just sort of
saw a notice for an open letter about
someone who'd been accused of racism and
thought
well i better sign that because i'm
against racism
and then you know days or weeks later it
all
broke out in the press it should be said
francis just before you asked your
question that
there was also a letter that later uh
was signed by many act people who are
actually experts in the field
in your support in your defense right
yeah so um
quillette magazine uh kindly organized
an open letter
in support of me or at least in support
of my academic freedom
uh once i had been fired from the
college in uh right at the end of april
and that was
that was a sort of short statement just
saying that we we support noah carl
and we opposed the injustice visited
upon him and that was signed by
over 600 academics and scholars from
around the world
including many in areas like
intelligence research
and human evolution and uh human
behavioral sciences i mean i thought you
were going to say when
when you interrupt me it just needs to
be said that i'm not racist
everybody who watches the show knows
that that is not true so there is no way
i could say
i know absolutely um no and i realize
you can't get into the specificities
of your case but again broad brush
strokes why why did these accusations
come about
so uh i think it's
reasonable to sort of lay out what the
main uh charges against me were
slightly more detail so they they
objected as i mentioned to the fact that
i'd attended this conference in london
called the london comrades on
intelligence which i can say a bit more
about in a second
they also objected to the fact that i'd
published and reviewed papers in a
journal
called open psych founded by a colleague
of mine
which again i can talk a little bit more
about if you'd like and then thirdly
they
objected although they didn't mention it
explicitly in the open letter
to a paper of mine published in an
evolutionary psychology journal
which was entitled how stifling debate
about race genes and iq can do harm so
quite a provocative title
but which made some i think quite
important and serious arguments about
the ethics of discussing these
topics which are considered very
controversial and what were the what was
the thrust of that paper
right so that paper um
made three main arguments in support of
the proposition that
stifling debate around race genes and iq
can actually do harm as opposed to good
the first argument was that by equating
as many people do
research on race genes and iq with
racism
by equating a proposition like part of
the
gap in average iq between one group and
another may be attributable to genetics
with the claim one group is genetically
superior to the other group
you're holding our morals hostage to the
facts you're saying that
if the science ever did suggest that
genes made a contribution to
the gap in average iq between two
different groups then that
group that scored higher would be
somehow entitled to oppress or exploit
or consider itself metaphysically
superior to the other group
which seems like a rather irresponsible
and dangerous position to take we don't
want
our morals to be determined by what the
next paper published in
nature or science finds we want our
morals
to be couched in robust ethical
principles that are
that can withstand the onslaught of
science that was the first main argument
the second argument was uh based
uh in large part on arguments that have
been made by stephen pinker in his book
the blank slate
he points out that
while certain political uh
parties most notably the nazis obviously
egregiously misused
uh science surrounding human population
differences
for appalling ends other political
ideologies or political
systems have misused the uh reverse
position i the point of view that we're
all blank slates and that biology plays
no role in the differences between us or
in the differences between groups
this rings a bell i i did grow up in the
soviet union so i have an idea what you
might be referring to yeah i think
uh that's absolutely right soviet union
being the most obvious example of this
um in in pinker's book he identifies
quotes from
prominent communist intellectuals in
which they
uh use the metaphor the metaphor of the
blank slate to describe how
humans are plastic and could be
manipulated
uh for political purposes and to make
them into sort of better um
you know uh individuals more
uh well disposed to life in a in a so
in a communist utopia i think
only the newborn child is spotless i
think as a quote from the khmer rouge
in cambodia great people yeah
not great guys we only killed 80 million
people man i know we're overpopulated
so yeah you can you can find quotes in
mao you can find quotes in the khmer
rouge
you can find quotes in some soviet
intellectuals and the
uh idea is that
any belief we may have about the nature
of
human psychology or human nature itself
can be manipulated for political
purposes there's nothing inherently
dangerous
about the biology plays a role end of
the spectrum as
as opposed to the biology plays no role
end of the spectrum
and hence again we should
try to build an ethically robust system
which
is logically independent of
scientific facts but which may be
informed by them to some extent
and then the third argument of the paper
was basically just that there have been
clear empirical examples of where
stifling debate around these topics
has done harm one of the examples i gave
in that section
was of research relating to
the election of donald trump
whether you support or you oppose donald
trump it's clear that many
very many people strongly oppose him and
consider his
that is the biggest understatement in
the history of trigonometry
he has engendered a certain amount of
criticism
to be said mate go into politics
i think i think so roger scrutin had a
wonderful quote which is that
he he appears to have some flaws of
character
[Laughter]
um in any case suppose you're strongly
uh against his presidency as many people
are and
uh you know it's obviously not
unreasonable to be strongly opposed to
it
you have to recognize that the uh
atmosphere of political correctness that
has
[Music]
um
up in the united states and in the west
more generally
did contribute to his election there's a
analysis um written up in collette by
a gentleman named zach goldberg where he
showed in a series of
statistical models that even after
controlling for measures of
anti-immigration sentiment and uh
ethnic prejudice opposition to political
correctness was still a strong predictor
of voting for trump
as opposed to hillary clinton and
there's some
anecdotal quotations in various news
sources from the
2016 campaign of people saying well you
know i've never voted republican before
and you know i don't particularly like
trump's policies but we just
have to do something about political
correctness and of course not all
opposition to
iq research or research into population
differences
is is a sort of juvenile
manifestation of political correctness
some of it's based on a serious
judgment about the harm that could be
done by this research but i think
a lot of it or at least a certain amount
of it is just a manifestation of
political correctness and
and the people who take that position
should recognize
that uh imposing political correctness
on others can often
lead to a backlash as it has done in the
case of donald trump
and but now when you started this
research was there not a small part of
your brain that just thought
i'm going to get into [ __ ] for this well
uh
one thing i should point out as i've
pointed out in um in a blog post
responding to some of the criticisms of
my work is that i've
not actually done any original research
on population differences
in intelligence or iq although i
obviously have shown an interest in it
and i am still interested in it
uh to this day uh but
certainly it crossed my mind that uh
publishing certain works or or attending
certain conferences might be
get me into trouble it was certainly a
risk i was willing to take given that
i got into academia because i'm
interested in finding out the truth
about
things and also interested in exploring
controversial topics as opposed to just
making incremental progress on things
that are already
very well understood indeed i would
argue that's
sort of our role as scholars to push the
boundaries of
of truth and of science uh and so i
felt at the time that while i might get
into a little bit of trouble
it's probably not gonna be too bad that
judgment seems on reflection
to have been somewhat mistaken because
we laugh about it but fundamentally we
were chatting just before
we started the interview essentially no
matter what the outcome of the legal
cases your career is over now
quite possibly yes i mean as i mentioned
to you in the in the pre-interview
discussion
i'd watched a interview with brett
weinstein
who along with his wife heather haying
was
dismissed from evergreen college
following a scandal in 2017
somewhat different from mine but
received
much more media attention and uh
professor weinstein and his wife have
many years of
teaching experience and clearly
uh very well established educators and
he was saying in the interview that i
watched that
after having been dismissed from
evergreen he's he still hasn't received
any job offers from universities
which is mind-boggling yeah we've we've
both met brett and they're lovely people
they're very balanced yeah
they are on the left yep and there i
mean
as i said to you jokingly you know you
are uh
an interesting and promising scholar but
they are people who have a 20 20 odd
year's career
of teaching and giving value to the
institution that they're represented so
the fact that
no one wants to hire them says quite a
lot about
what you said is you know cowardice
basically on behalf of many
yeah i mean yeah they would seem to be
just a total asset for any university
they've
got all that teaching experience they've
developed a public persona
of respectable and engaging
scholars and clearly are as you say
affable nice people who
simply want to understand the world and
promote knowledge and learning and yet
they haven't received a single offer
circles or at least haven't done so up
until that point so let's come back to
the paper
that you got criticized for the
particular point number one
which is uh the ethics of researching
race and iq and all these things i i
personally can totally see
why people would have a concern about
looking into whether different groups
ethnic groups in a society that's highly
polarized right now in a society where
this constant conversation about
structural oppression
people's worries about you know doing
recent research into whether you know
jews are more intelligent than black
people or white people are more
intelligent than latinos or all this
stuff
and the kind of things that that could
be used for the kind of things that
might come out of that
so what is the moral argument in favor
of that kind of research
well as i said um one argument is
that the alternative point of view has
also been misused and could also be
misused again
um and there are numerous examples
from recent history as again pinker and
others have pointed out
of a group that was considered highly
successful
uh being targeted for
discrimination or indeed much more
serious sanctions genocide
uh because it's the success was taken as
evidence
of its wickedness the you know the jews
in europe and
the middle east are the most obvious
example of this well this is why i
always say i'm i'm massively in favor of
iq research because it always shows jews
being on top so i'm very happy with that
um but but keep going sorry i was that's
okay
um so uh
one has to be aware of of that
other possibility namely that if that if
every
difference in outcome is attributed to
the environment and one group
ends up doing uh a lot better and
socioeconomically than some other groups
members of those other groups
may feel they have been
unfairly dealt with by society and
uh may target that that more successful
group as as was the case in
germany and indeed if we if we go to the
nazis
uh there's at least some evidence that
prominent nazi scholars were opposed to
the concept of psychometric intelligence
or iq as it's uh often known
precisely because it showed ashkenazi
jews living in germany to score higher
than non-jewish germans at the time
and it was described in in one source as
sort of an instrument of jewry
psychometric intelligence that is um
whereas one could imagine at the time
someone saying
well no the reason that jews own
you know more large businesses or
overrepresented in
high income professions maybe superior
maybe that they have higher average
cognitive ability in that superior i
wouldn't i wouldn't like to use
that mileage
i like to get some validation from my iq
um
okay but i do not understand people's
concerns about looking at those things
though
so i do understand their concerns and uh
the reason i wrote that paper was
precisely to address some of their
concerns i had to show that i didn't
just sort of
recklessly uh wander into this
controversial area without having
taken a moment to reflect on the ethics
at all
which is more than can be said i think
for many of my critics
but uh as i said the the first argument
in the paper which i think is the most
important one and that's the argument
that
if we if we characterize the area as
controversial
if we say it would be terrible if the
science term
turned out one way rather than another
what we're doing is saying
that there is some relationship between
what science
finds and what our uh policies
ultimately will be
whereas what whereas my point of view is
that
we should say now it doesn't matter what
the science uh
comes up with because certain ethical
principles
will still prevail the ethical
principles like
it's uh wrong for
members of one group to exploit or
oppress members of another group
regardless of the mean trait values for
certain
uh socially salient traits within those
two groups
and hence it can actually be harmful
to say that it's controversial we should
just say it's not controversial it's
just science some of the hypotheses that
have been advanced
may turn out to be wrong others may turn
out to be right
and let's treat them critically but
dispassionately like we would do
with uh in any other area of science
isn't it almost impossible though to
treat this subject dispassionately when
you've had you know
black people have the history of racism
and part of the
racism that they have faced is
essentially that they're a lower form of
human being
you see a lot of the time complaining uh
comparing them to apes and monkeys so
when someone comes along and goes
well we're going to do this study you
can understand
you know the sense of anger was just
well this is just going to legitimize
racism against me that has been
exposed to my people for hundreds of
years
yeah i mean that's a fair point and of
course some some of the claims are
you know simply wrong like that they're
somehow sort of lower form of humans or
more
more related to apes than than other
races
i mean obviously we're
you know there's one species of of homo
sapiens
divided into different populations which
some people
believe it's valid to refer to as races
and other people would prefer to use
other terms for but to address your
your point itself um
the best argument against someone saying
this group has a lower average iq
therefore we should exploit it is is not
to say
well that's not let's not ever try to
find out whether that's true it's to say
well it doesn't follow that just because
the mean value for some trait in that
group is lower that you are entitled to
exploit them
or that you're entitled to abuse any
particular individual because he or she
happens to be from that group
ie better to argue against someone's
defective moral reasoning than against
their scientific reasoning again as i
said because
in the future we may have
very good evidence that uh gaps that we
now observe in traits like cognitive
ability between groups are to some
extent genetic i'm not saying that
is true or will be shown to be true but
it could be and if the research doesn't
get done
in western countries like the uk or the
u.s it may get done
elsewhere where research in countries
where researchers don't feel so
restricted
so i think it's it's a losing battle in
the in the long run
to imagine that we won't find out the
answers to the questions
of course the answer may turn out that
genes don't make any contribution
i think that's somewhat unlikely but
it's it's certainly a possibility
so boesky what you're saying is the
chinese are going to do it next year
i mean the chinese may well undertake
research in this area that would be
um considered controversial or
or or beyond the pale in in the west
okay well that's very very interesting
not very ethnically diverse china though
so where are they going to get all this
study subjects
no absolutely that's the question um
but beyond maybe protecting the high iq
groups from persecution as you were
talking about in nazi germany
yes bring it back to the jews it's
always about the jews mate it's all
about the jews
this isn't the labour party conference
what other benefits are there to doing
this research
well i think one benefit that people
often
uh dismiss or or forget to talk about at
all is just
it's inherently interesting to know the
truth about things
as a as a scientist or a scholar
i like to know whether certain things
are true or false i don't like to
put a particular hypothesis away in
a box and put a padlock on it and lock
it so that we never find out whether
it's true or not
many philosophers at least in the
western canon probably elsewhere
as well have throughout history
distinguish between
three fundamental dizidorata
beauty morality or the good
and truth i think truth is can some
extent be considered
something that's valuable in and of
itself so that's pretty important as far
as i'm concerned
but also we have uh in social science
large numbers of people looking to
looking at questions like why are there
gaps between
self-identified racial groups and traits
like education
income homeownership
things like that and presumably we want
to know the actual answers to those
questions rather than to just assume
certain answers and then
ignore evidence of the contrary now
again this isn't to say that
uh the more controversial answers maybe
that genes make some contribution is
definitely correct but it's just some
it's something that has to be considered
if we want to look at those questions
seriously
and do you think that's why there's been
such a backlash to you
in this instance because essentially
some of the things that you're talking
about
challenge the mainstream narrative which
is everybody's equal and if anyone out
anyone's outcome differs from what
other groups are getting that is purely
because of discrimination do you think
that is the reason yeah i mean that's
that's clearly one of the reasons and
i'm certainly not
the first person to have fallen afoul of
that uh tendency and of course one
another thing
that we should remember here and another
which is a point that i made in my in my
paper that we've been discussing
is that we already know beyond a
reasonable doubt that
differences between individuals in
traits like iq
and other personality attributes are to
some extent genetic in origin there are
various different kinds of studies which
have shown this adoption studies show
that if you
uh if children are taken at birth and
adopted by different families they will
often turn out
as or more similar to their original
biological parents than to their
adoptive parents which suggests that
it's
genes they inherited from their original
biological parents it caused them
to turn out the way they did rather than
the
parenting that they received from their
adoptive parents at least in large part
then there are twin studies which you
may have heard of where
non-identical and identical twins are
compared
for similarity on a particular trait
such as cognitive ability
and what is typically found is that
identical twins who share
not only the intrauterine environment
but also
all of their genes except post
conception somatic mutations in genes
they tend to be much more similar
on a trait psychological ability than do
dizygotic
twins which share the intrauterine
environment
but only share half of their genes on
average like
fraternal siblings do and so that's
that's the sort of useful natural
experiment which tells us that the
greater genetic similarity of identical
twins
contributes to the greater phenotypic
similarity of identical twins
so in the last couple of decades even
more sophisticated methods have been
developed for looking at
the contribution of genetics to
individual differences in traits
things like genome-wide association
studies
which allows to pinpoint individual loci
in the genome which may
represent
the genes that cause specific
differences between individuals in these
traits
so all that evidence suggests that
or indicates very strongly that some
people have a higher average iq than
other people because they possess
certain genes which those other people
don't possess
does that mean that the people with the
higher iq and the
higher number of iq increasing genes are
superior
to the other individuals definitely yes
not very many people
of course not very many people
if anyone takes that proposition
seriously you say no you're
your moral worth you know either we all
have equal moral worth or your moral
worth is determined by
you know whether you do good deeds and
whether you um
act in a moral way in your everyday life
it's not determined by whether you score
higher or lower on a on a battery of
cognitive tests
and so i i would simply apply that same
logic to differences
between groups it's about saying that
all human beings have
equal value irrespective of which traits
they have genetically or otherwise yeah
it's about
pointing out that we we already know
again beyond a reasonable doubt that
some individuals
are genetically smarter than other
individuals that hasn't caused the
collapse of civilization
it hasn't caused the individuals with
the higher
propensity for a high genetic propensity
for cognitive ability
to say uh you know all the others must
genuflect before us and treat us as
demigods on earth because
we're slightly smarter on average it's
just the recognition of the fact that
there are individual differences in the
population
and there may also be average group
differences in the population
uh we don't yet know for sure but it's
something that could be the case
and what are the benefits of conducting
this type of research
if you think 10 20 30 50 100 years ahead
how could that benefit the human race
well as i've already
um argued i don't i don't think one has
to
cite a specific material benefit in
order to justify doing the research i
think as scholars we should
want to find out the truth about things
even if at the present time it doesn't
seem to be a material benefit however i
would
argue that there is likely to be a
material benefit not only
that's that um tail risk that i
discussed earlier of
avoiding you know persecution of more
successful groups
like like the ashkenazi jews but also
just in
understanding why are certain groups
different from one another and what kind
of
um policies
are likely to therefore be effective in
what kind of policies are likely to be
uneffective
for example if you propose a policy
based on the assumption that
genes play absolutely no role in a
particular group difference and it turns
out they do play a role
that policy may be a total waste of
money and it might be better to spend
that money in a different way
for example in just redistributing
income from one group to another i mean
as i as i argued in that in that paper
in the evolutionary psychology journal
there's a prominent
philosophy uh on the left
luck egalitarianism which basically says
that we can distinguish between the
choices people make during the course of
their lives
and the initial endowments they received
when they were born
that that includes not only endowments
like growing up in a large house or with
very wealthy parents but also genetic
endowments like
having a high propensity for a hygienic
propensity for intelligence
or hard work whatever it may be and
according to luck egalitarianism
it's reasonable to hold people to
account for the choices they make during
the course of their lives so if someone
commits a crime it's reasonable to send
him to jail and punish him
but if someone is born with a low
average with a low iq
it's not reasonable to hold him to
account for that because he or she
didn't do anything to deserve that low
iq and hence it's reasonable for the
society to get together and say that
individual
uh didn't have the same advantages as
everyone else so it's fair to
redistribute some money
to him or her or to provide additional
early childhood education or training
again i'm not saying that you have to
adopt this point of view but it's one
that can be reasonably argued for and
that doesn't commit us
to any sort of uh extreme
political philosophy of of social
darwinism or something like that
and how much does iq make a difference
in someone's life
having a high iq does it make a huge
difference or
so it can make quite a big difference it
depends of course on the domain
and it's not the only factor that makes
a difference other personality traits
make a difference you know which country
you were born in makes a huge difference
uh you know whether you had uh parents
with
connections or not makes a difference
but but to go to iq in particular
it has moderate correlations uh
with life outcomes observed
around age 30 or 40 if it's measured say
age 11 or age 16 in some domains
it can have incremental predictive
validity even within the top 1
so you might say well after a certain
point iq is no longer predictive
after say an iq of 120
uh more iq doesn't really benefit you
well in some domains it actually still
can benefit you there was a famous study
of
a group of people called them the uh
sorry the study was called the
mathematically precocious youth and
these were individuals who scored very
high on a mathematics test which isn't
exact which isn't identical to iq but
it's very similar
and they were followed up by researchers
into their
30s and 40s and it was found that
these individuals who represented the
top i think one percent of
of scorers in the relevant population
uh had achieved uh
lots of impressive things including
filing patents and publishing academic
papers and winning various kinds of
awards and they found that
those who scored in the top quarter of
the top one percent
had done more of those impressive things
than those who scored in the bottom
quarter of the top one percent
so it can be incredibly predictive
of course when it comes to a variable
like lifetime income
it's somewhat less predictive of course
it has a correlation with lifetime
income
but it's not not as strong as it is with
uh outcomes like uh educational
attainment
where there's a more obvious connection
from cognitive ability
to uh you know performance
in universities say and because of being
a former teacher
you know that we were very much drummed
into us that there was different
types of intelligence you know there's
academic but there's also special and
all the rest of it do you adhere to that
do you believe that that is a thing that
somebody can be
you know at school for whatever reason
not academic but they get into the world
of
business for example like alan sugar and
yeah so i think um the first thing to
say is that
uh when it comes to intelligence itself
psychometric intelligence the generally
accepted
position among researchers is that
uh there aren't different types of
intelligence although there are
uh different sub domains if that makes
sense
what you typically find when you give a
sample of people
a battery of cognitive tests say a
memory test and a verbal reasoning test
and a spatial reasoning test
uh a mathematical reasoning test is that
scores on each of the tests are
positively correlated meaning that the
people who do better on spatial
reasoning also tend to do better in
verbal reasoning and they also have tend
to have slightly better memories
and that means that a so-called general
factor
of cognitive ability can be extracted
using
some statistical methods which accounts
for a large
part of the differences in scores
between different individuals on those
tests
and that contradicts the point of view
that was
once somewhat fashionable in the
educational
uh literature that there were distinct
types of intelligence so you were either
sort of a
physio spatial learner or a verbal
learner
but once you extract this
general factor from the cognitive test
you do find that there are also
distinct subdomains which people may
excel to a greater or lesser degree so
some people may have so-called verbal
tilt they might be slightly better at
the verbal
tests on the i and not in the iq battery
than on the mathematical test and those
people might tend to go into
into fields like law or back to the jews
they may also go into politics for
example whereas people who
who have a sort of mathematical
visiospatial tilt might be more likely
to go into engineering
or into uh you know scientific research
and so the answer to your question is
it's sort of mostly incorrect but there
is a grain of truth to it in the sense
that
although the tests are all positively
correlated there are distinct sub
domains
like verbal intelligence and numerical
intelligence guys
we wanted to take a moment to say thank
you to every single one of you that has
supported us on patreon
subscribe star that sent us money
through paypal we could not do the show
without you
please keep supporting us and if you
haven't already please consider doing so
because that is exactly what allows us
to keep improving the show
every single week having said that we've
now also got a corporate sponsor to sell
out to
indeed we have and it is the magazine
the week and what the week does
is it pulls together the best articles
from over 200 different sources
from publications such as the times the
telegraph or for our one liberal
snowflake fan
the guardian they do exactly what we do
on the show which has pulled together
balanced opinions from different sides
so that you can make your own mind up
and you don't get stuck in an echo
chamber and if you want to take
advantage of this special offer
all you need to do is go to
theweek.co.uk
offer use our special code trigger and
you'll get
six free issues of the week the great
thing about the week is it allows you to
read less
and know more which is going to appeal
to people like francis who can barely
read
and it's not just news the week also
brings you the latest from the world of
sports so if you want to find out
what's going on in the transfer window
who manchester united are going to sign
the week will also deliver you the
latest freshest news on that
which won't appeal to someone like
constantine because he's a massive
virgin
i've been married for 15 years what the
[ __ ] are you talking about yeah it's
growing back
well anyway guys seriously we know that
you've got busy lives
we understand that you're not going to
be reading 200 articles a week
and that's what the magazine does it
brings together those articles in
one combined easy package that you can
read and know what's going on
join thousands at trust the week as
their essential curated news source
try it for yourself and get your first
six issues
completely free to take advantage of
this great offer
visit the week dot co dot uk forward
slash offer
enter our code which is of course
trigger and get your first six issues
completely free
uh just coming back to your case now
more broadly uh
as you know we believe in free speech
and
that means believing in freedom for
people that you may not agree with to
speak
their mind right is this your case is it
first and foremost about the principle
of freedom and academic research where
the idea being that you and i can grill
you for you and
francis and i can grow for 40 minutes
about what's the benefits of this
research but fundamentally it doesn't
matter because
an academic should have the freedom to
research whatever the hell they want
i mean that's very much my position is
that you can consider all this research
to be
either completely erroneous
or or sort of somewhat irresponsible
but you should still uphold the
principle that individuals
in this case academics should be free to
pursue lines of inquiry that they regard
as fruitful
and that you have every right to
criticize them in blogs and in journal
articles or newspaper articles or in
the form of verbal conversation or even
tweets
i mean one would hope you would do it
reasonably respectfully and not resort
to ad hominem
attacks or or attempts to impugn the
character of the researchers concerned
so my view is very much that academic
freedom is extremely important
and is under threat and should be
protected and do you think it's got
worse i mean
there's not only your case there's also
the case of dr jordan peterson who was
fired from cambridge university i think
for
was it appearing next to somebody in a
in a photograph a fan of his who had a
particular slogan on a t-shirt yeah so
he'd been invited
uh to uh take up a visiting fellowship
uh in the divinity faculty for a term i
think
to give a series of lectures that he'd
compiled on some aspect of the bible and
its psychological interpretation and
and he announced this on his youtube
channel
and some of his critics found out about
this announcement
and we don't exactly know what happened
after that but they presumably
petitioned the divinity faculty
and or the wider university
administration to have his
fellowship rescinded and a couple of
days later there was an announcement on
again on twitter
not necessarily the most formal uh
avenue for making such announcements
that said his
his application for a fellowship had
been rescinded following further review
and
it transpired later that
the student union had sent out a similar
tweet
even earlier than the
faculty of divinity itself which
implies but does not uh prove that they
were they were involved in the
campaign to have his uh fellowship
rescinded
well there was certainly privy to it
before one one presume that's almost
certainly the case
the most beautiful diplomatic answer
we've ever had well
just comparing freedom of academic
research and freedom of speech i feel
like i can make a pretty strong case for
why freedom of speech is important and
necessary why is academic freedom
of research important and necessary so i
think some of the reasons
are similar to ones that would be given
in defense of freedom of speech more
generally
for example that uh
we humans are actually often quite bad
at objectively appraising risk
so for example oh no that might
even that's how this show happened yeah
so evolutionary psychologists will point
out that we tend to have a much
stronger emotional response to a spider
or to the dark or to
snakes into a snake for example than we
do to a loaded gun
or a faulty electrical wire or say
driving without a seat bolt
even though at least in countries like
the uk where we don't have poisonous
spiders or snakes for the most part
i think um the the you know the loaded
gun
or the faulty electrical wire would be
much more objectively dangerous we just
don't have that same emotional response
because we evolved in an environment
where there weren't any faulty
electrical wires
but where there were poisonous snakes
and spiders
that might kill us if if they got too
close
and i think this uh sort of
cognitive bias applies more generally
and leads us to
catastrophize about the possible effects
of certain kinds of research
to a greater extent than is justified by
a more objective assessment and that's
obviously an argument that could be made
in defense of
free speech in general secondly
there's the streisand effect there's the
tendency for
censorship to backfire if you try to
prohibit all discussion of something
whether in whether in general in society
or in academia in particular
it's likely to get even more attention
than
it would have done otherwise i mean i
think that almost certainly applies in
my case
almost no one had heard of me before
this
huge controversy erupted uh it's
it's unlikely i have to be honest that
my research
or my writings in general would have
gotten very much uh readership how were
it not for
the huge spotlight on them that was
generated by the um
the open letter for example that paper
that we were discussing earlier in the
interview
i think had around 3000 downloads uh
before the open letter against me was
published it now has about 23 000
so that's an additional 20 000 downloads
that
uh could perhaps or in large part be
attributed to
to the co to the controversy
so there's that stride zone effect if
you if you consider this
research to be as dangerous
as you say you do trying to censor it
may actually lead to more people hearing
about it and wanting to find out about
it
and then uh thirdly there's just
obviously the fact that we
do want to find out the truth about
things and
we our role as academics
i think should be to pursue
fruitful lines of inquiry and scientific
data
wherever they may lead not to act as
arbiters of what should or shouldn't be
allowed to be discussed in society
uh jonathan height the american
psychologist
and free speech campaigner has an
excellent lecture
up on youtube called two incompatible
sacred values
at american universities and he talks
about this conflict that has emerged in
the last decade or so
between free speech and academic freedom
and truth on the one side and
the uh movement to stifle certain
discussion of certain topics and to
impose
uh a sort of
framework of language that
doesn't seem very natural to us on some
topics
and he argues that universities are
gonna face a choice
uh going forward between retaining telos
or truth as their ultimate
purpose or whether they are going to
adopt
a sort of dual purpose of truth and also
social justice
he shows in his lecture that uh if we
consider the
shields of universities like harvard and
yale
they have the word veritas on them which
means truth
indicating that the founders of these
universities
saw truth as um
one of the probably the ultimate goal of
these educational institutions
whereas now if you read some of the
mission statements of universities
particularly in the us
you'll say they will say things like
promoting diversity
inclusion and equity and academic
freedom and of course
that it's all very well and good until
you recognize that these things can come
into conflict with one another
i would argue that truth should prevail
when it comes into conflict with other
values which are
valid for people to hold um and i don't
think universities should
function as centers for teaching
learning
and the promotion of a particular
political point of view i think they
should just
focus on the first two and
from what we've seen now with academics
losing their jobs do you think this is a
trend that is going to get worse now
um very hard to say i mean it's it's
it's notoriously uh unwise to make
predictions
i don't see any obvious sign of it
getting better
um i mean it seems to be part of this
more general phenomenon that has been
called the the great awokening something
that's happened since about 2012.
in in uk us
and some other western countries
suddenly we see
a dramatic shift in political attitudes
on certain subjects particularly on the
left
in america we see increases in the
volume
of google searches for terms that
once seem very strange like
intersectionality and white privilege
and cultural appropriation um we've seen
following some excellent analyses by a
guy called david rosado and the guy i
mentioned earlier zach goldberg
that the frequency of usage of those
sort of woke terms
in the newspaper of record in america
the new york times has increased
precipitously just in the last decade or
so
so there seems to be some kind of
general phenomenon
um worthy of study
which is affecting not only the wider
culture but also
the freedom of academics to pursue lines
of inquiry that
the promoters of this phenomenon
consider to be
objectionable and the last time we saw
each other was it was at a slightly
secret academic conference which was on
this very subject
i thought you're going to say slightly
seedy
i didn't feel with cd but speak for
yourself all the people who were there
watching this and now they know how you
feel about it yeah i know that's what i
thought you were going to do slightly
it was slightly secretive but it wasn't
cd no it wasn't yeah
disappointingly so anyway well done for
sidetracking me for a whole 20 seconds
for no purpose whatsoever thanks man
but what i noticed at that conference
was a very strong feeling certainly from
the people who were there and
some of them were very distinguished
people was that there is a culture of
fear in academia which is exactly what
we see
in comedy in in many different fields of
the arts there's a culture of
the certain things which must not be
talked about and if you talk about them
or if you do them or if you
you know publicly discuss some of these
concepts that you talk about in the
great awakening
you will be punished do you think there
is that culture in academia now where
people
stay away from certain subjects and in
fact in many cases feel like they have
to come out and criticize someone like
you without even knowing anything about
your case
because of that uh absolutely and so i
mean it's hard to
collect systematic data which is
something i would always like to see in
order to make it
before making it strong you can tell
he's a scholarship yeah
but there are certainly huge numbers of
anecdotal reports
of people self-censoring
or indeed of signing petitions
denouncing
someone or denouncing an area of
research even when they themselves
disagree with the
statement of the petition i mean i've
certainly
heard individual cases myself and i've
also heard other people report
that they know of such cases um
so you're you're absolutely right i mean
one
ray of hope is that
at least in surveys most academics do
still
say that they believe in academic
freedom and an environment of
open debate on campus as opposed to one
characterized by restrictions um when
you can can't stay in certain areas
so that was a survey done in 2017 i
believe
by a guy called sam abrahams which found
that about
80 percent if i remember the figure
correctly of academics in america
prefer the atmosphere of open inquiry
and debate to the
one that's restricted in the interests
of protecting
certain groups who are allegedly
at risk of harm so that would suggest to
me
if the result is correct that there's a
sort of 20
on the fringe that are accounting for a
disproportionate share
of all the mobbing attempts and
all the sensor i
it's an 80 20 rule you know this idea
going back to um the
late 19th century early part of the 20th
century 20 of
italian landowners owned 80 of the land
in italy
often we find that a small group can
exert disproportionate effect on some
larger phenomenon and so if this isn't
if this is indeed true
one way to counteract the growing
censorship on campus
might be to tell you know the members of
the 80
you know you're in the 80 percent i.e
the emperor is actually naked he's not
wearing any clothes and we all recognize
this
i let's sort of speak up in unison and
say
we don't have to agree with someone to
defend their right to freedom of
expression and let's
have a civilize discourse in which we
focus on criticizing arguments
and data and methodology rather than
people's character or motives
but you say that but it just seems like
for instance i
i before i started this show i was never
aware of the you know the problems on
campus uh we had lionel shriver a few
weeks ago not months ago talking about a
professor
who uh in harvard who went to defend uh
harvey weinstein
not defend his actions
yeah and you know he was he was fired as
a result
and so you think well if if that's where
we are where somebody is legitimately
doing a job and everybody has a right to
a legal defense
loses their their livelihood as a result
where are we well i know i mean that
case was again extraordinary in my
opinion because
as you said he wasn't defending the
actions of harvey weinstein
if he had done so which he of course
should have the right um
to do that i think could could
reasonably be argued
uh would compromise his role as dean but
he wasn't defending the actions he was
just defending the man
in court as as any
um person who's taken to court
uh is entitled um
to be the
uh what almost only happened in that
case is that the
administration of his college or of
harvard in general were
petitioned and
uh sort of bombarded with complaints
from
students and their defenders within the
within the faculty saying
you know this this person is making it
hard for me to study this person is
um causing me to feel unsafe i can't i
can no longer go to this person and
divulge all the stresses and anxieties
and i'm feeling
can you please make this go away and
although there were
high-minded op-eds written and probably
in the new york times places like that
defending the principles it was just
easier for the college to say well look
all this um
all this program or and all these
complaints
are going to disappear if we just take a
quick decision now
i was sort of taking the path of least
resistance even if the administrators
themselves
agreed with the principal they just
found it simpler and easier
to give in to calls for his um
dismissal or at least dismissal from
that role you talk about the ray of
light i actually as an outsider the idea
that 20
of academics don't believe in freedom of
academic research to me that sounds sky
high
and isn't one of the reasons for that as
jonathan high has written about
that over the last 40 or 50 years
the academy has become increasingly
left-wing
statistically yeah i mean that's a
that's a fair point in an ideal world it
should be
in my opinion zero percent of academics
who
aren't in favor of an atmosphere of of
open debate and
and free inquiry but 20
is a lot better than 80 and if one
were to assume that uh almost
all academics who hold uh
say left-wing opinions were in favor of
the sort of social justice politics that
manifest itself in opposition to free
speech
then one would assume that the figure
were far greater than 20
but according to that survey anyway it's
it's just 20
um so to your point about the
composition of the academy you're
absolutely right
that according to the data collected by
height and some other data collected by
the gentleman mentioned earlier sam
abrahams
over the last few decades going back to
say the 1970s
or even earlier there's been a increase
in the proportion of faculty who
identify
as left-wing or liberal and a
corresponding decrease in the proportion
who identify as conservative
now there's if we if you take the 20th
century as a whole there's obviously
no strong connection between um
left versus right and uh preference for
censorship
then maybe there's a tendency for sort
of centrist regimes to be
less sensorious than the more extreme
ones but we've seen censorship on the
right
obviously in the form of nazis but also
in the form of you know mccarthyism
in the united states in which there were
uh
certain witch hunts against
academics with communist views or
allegedly communist views
nowadays censorship seems to be
largely on the political left at least
in the universities
there are still attacks that should be
mentioned on academics from
conservative factions operating outside
the university
it's occasionally academics uh
infringe on the sacred values of certain
religious groups and find themselves
under attack but they usually get the
defense of their institutions in those
cases
uh in the cases like in the cases in
which
a left-wing sacred value
is threatened it's often true that the
the individual in question the
individual who's threatening that
sacred value doesn't receive any
protection within everyone's institution
or as indeed dismissed by them
as i was or as jordan peterson was at
cambridge university as well
and why is it that these universities
don't seem to have the backbone
backbone or moral spine to go
no we this person is conducting research
you may deem this person to be
controversial but that is simply your
opinion which you're allowed to express
but you do not have the right to demand
that someone be fired
well one reason i think is a reason that
i've already touched on which is that
there's a there's a number of true
believers in in the university faculty
in the university administration
so um sam abraham has shown
in yet another survey that university
administrators in the u.s
are even more skewed to the left liberal
end of the spectrum than our academics
themselves
and they are the people who are often
deciding whether a certain person should
be sanctioned or
or dismissed or defended many of those
people i'm sure
would be principal defenders of free
speech but if there are true believers
among them
then then the principle doesn't matter
they're not going to implement it
another interesting reason which has
been widely discussed
is the increase in university tuition
fees both
in the uk and across the pond which
have led to
students uh being treated like consumers
rather than like scholars they pay a
huge
relatively large upfront cost to go to
university and when they get there they
don't want to
confront ideas that uh they consider
hurtful
or damaging psychologically
they want to get their degree and not
have to
not have to be challenged and since
they're paying such a large number of
money they don't see
why they should be so there's a there's
a conflict there which isn't easily
resolved
because if enough people
and if enough students uh
prefer to not be challenged or offended
then universities will lose enrollment
if they uh if they
uphold academic freedom for
controversial points of view because
fewer students will apply there
however my senses from the few uh
individual cases that there have been in
which one might
test these arguments is that it's
actually the opposite
i.e there are more students that care
about academic freedom and free speech
than there are students
who adhere to the sort of social justice
view of the world i there's this sort of
silent majority as one might describe it
comprising people who may not hold
controversial
opinions or point of view themselves but
recognize the importance
of airing these opinions and discussing
them openly so for example
if my memory serves at evergreen
college in the u.s the college from
which brett weinstein had the hiring
were dismissed
there was a drop in enrollment in the
year after their dismissal
which suggests but does not um prove
that students were turned away by the
controversy there and about
um were um
not enamored of the manner in which
those two scholars were
fired from their positions i think there
was a similar drop in enrollment at
middlebury college following the
controversy surrounding a talk given by
charles murray
i don't know how many other cases there
have been but it would be worth sort of
systematically analyzing them to see if
the net effect of dismissing someone is
to reduce
rather than increase your enrollment
and perhaps if colleges and universities
could be persuaded
uh of that they would be less willing to
buckle under pressure
well let's hope that's what happens in
your case i hope so spoil students so
bring back corporal punishment anyway um
noah thank you very much for coming on
the show we've got time for one last
question which always is
what is the one thing no one's talking
about that we should be talking about
okay so for me uh this is something that
a few people are talking about but in my
opinion
one that not nearly enough people are
talking about which is
uh the fact that our cities are growing
increasingly
ugly i.e that
for every beautiful new building that is
constructed
19 or 20 ugly buildings are constructed
and indeed uh one of the few people who
has been making the case for
beautiful architecture so roger scrutin
was recently
fired from his role as a government
advisor on this matter following a sort
of
hit job in the new statesman and so i
think many many more people need to be
talking about
the fact that we need
physical beauty in our lives and that
much of it
has been taken away from us at least in
the uk
over um the last few decades
and that it's a sort of it's a public
good it's the most important public good
in society that no one or
only people like sir roger scrutin and a
few others want to talk about
we obviously recognize or many people
believe that the
service is a really valuable public good
in society
uh many people believe that education
and the natural
environment are important public goods
but no one
seems to or very few people seem to
mention that the
beauty of the streets we walk down going
to work or on a way to the shops are
also a public good and we should
um you know fight to defend that public
good
against uh encroachments of of
increasing ugliness i'm woke so i don't
see beauty
anyway on that note thank you so much
for coming noah
uh it's been an absolute pleasure if
people want to follow you online on your
twitter
what what is your twitter handle uh noah
carl 90.
no nicole 90. fantastic stuff um and
if uh people want to donate to you and
because of your legal
uh legal proceedings how can they do
that uh so the
the website is support noah carl and
yeah you can
make a donation uh there of
any size that appeals to you and would
be really grateful
well you you've raised i think 80 80
over 80 000
already that's right uh and obviously
your legal case will
take some uh do we wish you all the best
with that uh as always follow us
at trigger pod on all the social media
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
and we will be back in a week's time
absolutely and please leave us a nice
review on itunes particularly if you're
from the united
states or a board because that means our
podcast gets seen
globally if you enjoy it if you like it
share it
tell a friend or the rest of it and we
will see you soon thanks a lot guys see
you next week
[Music]
you